what's going on reject nation i'm greg
album what's your name oh it's John
every once in a while on this channel we
do a try not to laugh challenge and
we've got this one so everybody about
three to four people even if you have to
smile you have to replay the video
immediately even if your little pumpkin
this sounds like a challenge indeed
people hey guys but before we do that
we're bringing something a little bit
different to you today but totally
exciting recently we've partnered with
draftkings to bring you an NFL showdown
contest just in time for playoff
football want to tell them what that
means Johnny
it means Gregory that you could win up
to $50,000 so here's how it works you
draft for offensive player and two
defensive players and watch the points
roll in put together a great lineup and
you could walk away a little better than
when you started
oh and with a $5 deposit this particular
contest is 100% free to enter did you
say free that's right I said free free
yes free so make sure to get your line
of sin by 6:40 p.m. Eastern Time this
Sunday 3:40 Pacific spaces are filling
up as we speak so act fast people click
that link in the description box and get
signed up today fifty thousand dollars
did you say free free all right John no
laughing so no smiling I've never had
one of these on actual YouTube
[Music]
hi my name is Paul I am new to the
single scene I'm looking for a discreet
relationship that
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
shirts coming off
there's a guy under that entirely
possible
it's mental work
Jeff you couldn't stop my snake you know
my snake oh wow I was a chain reaction
[Music]
he doesn't
[Music]
I'm not so family for you
now we have two reefs thats the rules
after all you know how long we're gonna
be here for this is gonna take all day I
thought you were the one who does this
all the time gene over here in the
corner holding it down right now someone
goes to the gym cracks your head open
and you're all giggles use that all the
time at the chin so damn it okay all
right really ever serve this from the
beginning give me just take it back by a
little bit started from the beginning of
that clip okay that's how we'll play the
game just because you guys aren't gonna
watch us do this all over again
what where did her head go
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that is the face John makes
[Music]
[Music]
that was like my home
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa never thought about that
[Music]
the same guy
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well kids getting hurt it's funny that
let's change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh almost made it yeah well done we only
broke once I broke once there are a few
times though where I was literally
biting the inside of my cheek I got in
the zone I think I've really locked in
it's go time you know you let it out
through sarcasm you repressed humor with
sorry cats making comments but uh you
know I feel like I was able to rein in
my laughter game now there were times
where I was literally squeezing with the
inch out of my cheeks together I found
it funny how you were most people
suppress bad things with humor and you
suppress happiness with you are you
suppressing I just kind of naturally
smiled everyone what I'm like what do I
do that yeah so it's so to not smile was
really hard for me at times man because
there were times where I just really
felt like at least smiling there's a
voice video with this seal what it said
like that night some of these are just
really cool and interesting that's why
I'm a big fat Greek weddings hilarious
yeah cultures right oh damn then what
about white girls and Michael yeah yeah
there were a few where I was really
biting the inside of my cheeks man but
there's some that are just cool like
when Jesus was real and he is black dude
that was my favorite thing of this whole
compilation I mean that was just so
impressive to watch oh cool dude that
guy's so aerodynamic the one with the
pair using the filter with the things
for a guy of his mouth
kid crying that almost got me too man
but no no nothing beats where's the one
that are really like because there's two
spots where you can put your feet or
it's not like crazy to look at it's just
such a it's just a fluid motion you're
just like and there she goes oh God it's
it's a perfect well guys I think we did
it
I think we did it that was that is one
of the I gosh I gotta show my girlfriend
that moment cuz that was a funny ass
moment yeah right now alright guys well
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification about to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and make sure to click that link in
the description box
sign up with draftkings today and to
that content so that was my $50,000 of
possibility we're signing up let's do it
together jump on it